I'm not an organized person,
so I have had kids stuff hiding in corners for years.
And I finally did the big overhaul
and organized all of their papers and art.
Now I know what you're thinking, Lisa.
This looks like a manic cleaning frenzy.
And you would be right. Got the idea from this person on Pinterest.
And then I went to my favorite website,
Teachers Pay Teachers,
and got all of these print outs for the labels for my boxes.
With two kids who are now in third and fourth grade,
there has been a lot of backup.
I did a really good job of organizing their stuff for a couple years,
but it's gotten out of hand since then.
The original post that I found
had all of the instructions on what to buy.
I'm also gonna link that in my Amazon store,
cause once I got going, this actually went really quickly.
Then I got to decorate the fronts and make it fun for the kids,
and I really hope I can keep up with this.